California bill could result in loss of
custody
for parents who don't affirm children's
gender this is an actual law they're
passing I thought it was a joke as well
so a video in which a patent an attorney
obliterated representative Wilson's Back
peddling on child abuse claims and vague
terminology if you want to have that put
that clip up Rob you got the Twitter
link here California AB 957 known as the
tgiu empowerment act could lead to child
abuse accusations against parents
involved in custody battles if they do
not affirm their children's chosen
gender identity the bill initiated on
Assembly women Lori Wilson aims to
prioritize the parent who best affirms
the child selected identity and custody
disputes however the legislation does
not explicitly Define what affirmation
entails to proposed law considers
affirming a child's gender identity as
part of their health safety and Welfare
if grants the court it grants the court
system the ability to make custody and
visitation decisions based on appearance
affirming of their child's gender
identity and by the way this lady gives
us talk you don't have to play the whole
thing but play the first 30 seconds
maybe a minute and then we'll respond to
it I am Aaron Friday lead of our duty an
attorney and a mother of a girl who used
to believe that she was a boy
ab957 is the first bill in the nation to
codify into law that a parent who does
not affirm the gender identity of the
child is abusive there is no Nuance in
this bill it matters not the age of the
child the absurdity of the identity
adopted comorbid mental health issues or
persistence Family Court judges will be
compelled to favor the child who will
affirm the child's delusion parents can
easily gain the system and use gender as
retaliation against each other what
happens when one parent will socially
affirm the child but will not agree to
medicalize does the parent willing to do
more transitioning prevail
AB 957 unambiguously states that the
health safety and Welfare of the child
includes a parent's affirmation of the
child's gender identity you can pause it
right there Sean what's your reaction to
this
that
um the reaction is Lori Wilson is
pandering to the Mob
um where she probably gets donations and
things and what she's putting is it
custody is such an important thing you
know equality of custody and it is so
important that parents both get a fair
Shake because kids are going through a
stressful thing called the divorce kids
at 10 years old are being asked to take
a stance against mom or dad buy mom or
dad this puts kids in incredibly
stressful situations in the first place
and now you're asking a kid to put
something else on the table or be
manipulated on something else and then
the parents go after each other look
divorce and custody battles in this
country are are flamethrowers enough and
now this lawyer is correctly pointing
out that this bureaucrat Lori Wilson is
putting AB 957 out there that in
addition to do you support public school
or private school do you let them hang
out with their friends or Nazi let them
have a cell phone or not all these
things come up in divorce cases divorce
cases and custodies have been flipped on
what age would you allow the kid to have
a phone to text their friends and judges
are going one parent or another on on
freedoms and Disobedience now you're
just putting Another Log on this great
big fire an absurd log which she points
out does not have clear definitions of
what all this
affirmation is this is uh this is lunacy
under if you step back a little bit even
more Tom look I mean we talk about
gender affirming care I mean we don't
have that term but you guys have here
let me just step back a little bit and
ask a simple question why can you not
have sex with a child
it's illegal they're underage but why
but why is that because the child can't
consent to sex a child cannot make the
decision to have sex which sex is a
normal thing for human beings to do but
a child can consent to change their sex
is that what is that what you're telling
me correct a child can is capable
they're not allowed to drink they're not
allowed to smoke they're not allowed to
take certain drugs they're not allowed
to get married they're not but they are
interested in the Army right but they
can make this decision is that what
you're telling me and if if you don't as
a parent affirm them the government is
going to take them away and give them to
what
what did you see Bill Maher's speech on
uh on he sums up the speech this way
talking about exactly what you're
talking about he said when I was young I
wanted to be a pirate I'm so glad that
my parents didn't send me out for eye
removal and peg leg surgery right yeah
exactly I and I have a personal
experience with this because I have
three younger sisters the middle one
when she she was seven years old this is
like in the in the 90s back home so like
you this thing wasn't around right and
she said to my mama I'm a boy and she'd
run around claiming she's a boy well
she's grown up now she's the most
feminine beautiful young woman just got
married last year in Armenia to an
Armenian guy like when she was seven she
thought
she was a boy okay kids don't know what
they're doing that's why they're kids
that's why we protect them they all have
faces they have to be protected from
each themselves too right where does
this idea come from that they can just
suddenly decide what they are and we
gotta throw the whole way of the medical
system add them to facilitate that yeah
I'm so glad you shared the the story of
your sister because when you humanize
these stories it's like all right these
are real people with real stories and
there's a beginning middle and end to
these stories I grew up with two girls
that were like the two girls that played
with all the boys in sports okay
fast forward they were like tomboys we
all remember tomboys right this was a
this was a thing that we're all very
familiar with now what happened to these
two girls one ended up growing up
becoming a lesbian she's a feminine
lesbian she's a woman okay the other
girl we ended up dating in high school
she's a woman in full-on which she's now
married with kids but like these stories
when you're seven you're 10 you're 12
and you think that you're a pirate or
you think that you're a boy you're gonna
evolve like I thought I was a dinosaur
when I was seven years old I'm not
walking around you know on two legs over
here with a little arms out here but if
you don't give children the ability to
grow up and evolve and you basically
castrate them or cut them off or
harmonize them you don't give them the
ability to figure it out later on in
life and that is the truest crime well
my buddy Francis so that we do
trigonometry with uh he used to be a
teacher for 12 years
um and he always tells the story he says
I had this kid who's about nine years
old and I said to him what do you want
to be when you grow up and the kid
looked him when I want to be a dog
that's kids yeah exactly right
that's that's the level they're
operating at you know at least you
didn't see cat
we don't got to go there by the way this
is somebody just commented GM and said
Jeff younger's ex-wife took his son uh
he gave a Super Chat to took his sons to
Cali for that exact reason he would be
great man to talk to if you type in Jeff
young ex-wife you'll see the story you
guys have seen this before they get a
divorce a wife moves to California to
take advantage of the the law so his
their son could transition okay pretty
wild when you think about some of these
things that's taking place but by the
way this leads to
Newsome's media blitz fueling
presidential talk page four he was on
Hannity and a lot of people said he
destroyed Hannity a lot of people say
that that it wasn't Hannity's best luck
Newsome went in there ready and looked
strong California governor Gavin news
some increased media presence has
sparked speculation about his
presidential Ambitions with Democratic
strategist Steve maviglo suggesting I
buy that he supports the president but I
also think that he wants to be there in
case God forbid there needs to be an
alternative if something happens to the
president or if somebody else mounts a
challenge Newsome's recent confrontation
with Florida Governors Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis and his media engagement
including interviews with foxman's Sean
Hannity as intensified the speculation
Newsome has called DeSantis a small
pathetic man uh has and raised the
possibility of pressing charges against
Florida officials Fernand amandi a
democratic pollster notes that newsom's
attacks on the Santas have been well
received by democrats in Florida and
nationally so what is this a publicity
stunt is this a a preparation for
presidential run what do you think is
going on here with Newsome Tom uh I
think he's this is a run and we're just
waiting for the DNC and we've been
talking about this on this podcast with
some factual things that have been
coming up the DNC hasn't taken a stance
on certain things the DNC has been
leaking at certain times non-favorable
Biden articles to people like the New
York Times there is a back room
undercurrent going on here that if you
look at it you do not have to be a
conspiracy theorist you look at it he is
saying I'm running and he is putting his
group together but the DNC and the
Democrat machine is not fully supported
that yet and Newsome I believe is
standing at the door saying come on guys
wave the flag green flag here let's go
racing wave the flag I think that's
exactly what Newsome's doing and he's
positioning himself he's taking
advantage of not just photo ops but
places to put an opinion out that is a
national uh political position I think
that's what's going on here Newsome is
just waiting for the DNC to open the
door and say game on I actually disagree
with Tom on this and we'll see how this
plays out right the big one
I think this is not a jocking for
position I think this is an insurance
policy God forbid Biden is not equipped
we don't have I mean he falls exactly
God forbid that Biden is not able right
it's an insurance policy words correct
well they're gonna still prop him up and
he's still gonna be the guy that he's
gonna be running in in 2024 but I think
whether it's the DNC doing this whether
that's his uh internal team that's
basically saying hey stay ready stay
fresh because it's almost like an
athlete saying hey we don't know if MJ
is going to be able to play tonight
buddy all right now I'm not definitely
not comparing Biden to MJ all right that
just being out there but just in case
he's not ready
stays right exactly yeah exactly he
still put up 45. but just stay ready
just got hurt exactly are you ready yeah
so by the way I think uh if you know if
you if you watched any of that stuff
that he did with Hannity he dismantled
Hannity it was not a good look for
Hannity on his own show if you were just
tuning in and saw that you would thought
you would think that was the Gavin
Newsom show and that Hannity was the one
basically backpedaling and trying to
answer questions uh to his comments
about the Santas we've met DeSantis uh
he is neither small nor pathetic but he
is I can confirm amen so that is uh okay
that that is by the way this the soul
polls is favoring Trump more and more
and the santis is flatlining based on
numbers that just came out uh Trump
cruises DeSantis flat lines in polling
even after bombshell indictment this is
political story that just came out so
the sentences marketing teams got to get
to work RFK strategy just so you know if
the sentences team is listening here's
rfk's strategy he's getting more
eyeballs than DeSantis rfk's going to
podcasts long form podcasts and he's
sitting there in the line of fire taking
questioning let me say that one more
time to send this is campaign this is
our governor the reason why we moved to
Florida is because of the great
phenomenal job he did but he's got to
get in the firing line and start taking
the questions go on the top 20 podcasts
out there long form two hours and talk
and sell and debate sell America sell
the future sell your family sell what
values and principles and that momentum
will come back up because this strategy
the old school 1990s way of running for
office
does not work today and RFK is at 15
points without a single person on
mainstream media giving them anything
yeah he's at 15 points RFK hey if you
enjoyed this short hope you want to
watch the whole thing click over here
but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once here it's
called The Vault conference where 3 000
CEOs executive entrepreneurs from around
the world come together to strategize
for three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be they'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will gudara
the guy that ran 11 Madison in New York
if you run a business if you're a CEO
entrepreneur and executive this is not
an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August and September take care
everybody
thank you